all right we have breaking news tonight
the hills John Solomon is out with yet
another big blockbuster breaking news
story this time John Solomon reveals
Hillary Clinton she may have received
special treatment now from the FBI
during its investigation into the
handling of classified information on
that server you know the one where she
destroyed it all and bleach pit at all
now according to the FBI in that report
the deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe
issued an email declaring that the
Clinton investigation has been given
quote special status and would be
handled by a small team of high-ranking
FBI officials Wow
also tonight Hillary Clinton is saying
the appointment of a special counsel to
investigate uranium one would be an
abuse of power here now national
security strategist former deputy
assistant to the president sebastian
Gorka dr. korkor this on top of the fact
that we now know Comey was writing the
exoneration letter before he did his
investigation this goes into him
changing the words extreme carelessness
instead of gross negligence all done on
purpose seriously what McNabb did he who
are these people why did she get special
consideration no equal justice under the
law that's the real question Sean if you
or I had put secret top secret s ap
emails onto a private server do you
think McCabe would have written emails
detailing how our case was being
specially handled by senior FBI agents
being shut away from the average
procedures inside the bureau I don't
think so
the question is does having the last
name Clinton mean that you get a pass
you get a pass on doing things that are
illegal that you have things such as
serious investigations relabeled simply
matters to deflate their significance
the decisions are made before the
investigation is actually executed so we
have a problem
don't get me wrong I've worked with
thousands of FBI agents and analysts and
they're fine Patriots and they're
keeping us from this nation safe but
the highest level of the Bureau we have
issues and McCabe's behavior during his
wife's political campaign as an FBI
senior agent actually on social media
promoting his Democrat wife his wife
receiving hundreds of thousands of
dollars
there are hatch issues as well which
raised the question of just how
impartial is mccabe it seems not at all
especially when you put it all together
and they will read a lynch meeting and
changing the language and making
decisions ahead of time and I am told
from my sources tonight this is only
going to get worse the fix was in as
I've been saying now what about the
Republican House and Senate
investigators today launching their
effort to secure the evidence from
federal agencies about this uranium one
deal the corruption case as they prepare
to interview the FBI informant this food
foreman was telling the FBI a year and a
half before uranium 1 that there was a
network in the United States he had his
own experience he had emails he had
documents he had tapes where he knew
bribery extortion money laundering
racketeering was all happening this is
up not on not only that Sean I mean you
you drew up your slides yesterday we're
magnificent those should be used in a
court of law to prosecute everybody
involved with uranium one who undermined
the American national security but the
the fact here is we have a very very
serious issue of not only is the law
being done but is it seen to be done as
well as is justice blind or is there
special preferential treatment being
given this this story gets deeper and
deeper and deeper and don't forget the
letter we all read a Lynch threatened
threaten that person without loss of
freedom a matter not an investigation
right judge Roy Moore public